the fans miss you guys thank you very
much for being here
but most importantly our kobe bryant
mvp award tonight goes to giannis
attenua
[Applause]
oh
congratulations on the mvp trophy
thank you thank you it's sunday but the
bank was open for you today
quite a bit actually you know it was uh
usually it's close but for me was open
it was extended hours
and uh you know i called ahead so it was
open what's it like when
every shot's just going in like the way
it was tonight it's fun you know it's
fun um
i was happy my teammates had fun and you
know just being around great players
is just easy to play with you also had
some amazing moments with your son on
the sideline what will you remember most
about this all-star
experience definitely my son uh this is
the first time he's uh
coming to watch me play an all-star game
and uh you know this is for him
and uh it's just fun to have family
around
well congratulations enjoy thanks for
being here and putting on a great show
and performance thanks to all of you for